merci la pole et à monsieur guy teissier
merci merci monsieur le président après
mon collègue et ami herbillon ma
question s'adresse à madame le ministre
de l'éducation nationale je souhaiterais
et madame vous alerter sur les
difficultés de recrutement grands
comptes des professeurs des écoles du
premier degré d'appel rapport budgétaire
du sénateur jean claude carle et
françoise férat premier en novembre
dernier les démissions d'enseignants
stagiaires ont augmenté entre 2012 et
le taux triplant dans le premier degré
doublant dans le second degré dans les
années de référence jusqu'en novembre
les recrutements sur la liste
complémentaire pour pallier les
démissions des professeurs stagiaires
fonctionner normalement
l'académie faisait appel aux candidats
sur liste complémentaire dans l'ordre du
classement
or le 20 novembre dernier le rectorat de
l'académie aix-marseille informer les
candidats sur la liste complémentaire
qu'il n'y avait plus de budget pour six
recrutements
malgré les démissions qui perdure les
recrutements sont donc interrompues par
des élections par la direction de votre
part décision de votre ministère les
postes donc ne sont plus pourvus
certains postes sont pris par des
remplaçants ce qui occasionne par
ailleurs un manque de remplaçants dans
certaines circonscriptions
cette situation va donc urgent d de
grosses difficultés au niveau des
affectations à la rentrée prochaine
puisqu'il manquera des professeurs des
écoles
c'est une nation plus de nous interroger
sur les raisons qui conduisent autant de
stagiaires a dit mme des bichonner
faut-il y voir notamment des lacunes
dans la formation initiale ou des
difficultés tout simplement à enseigner
dans certaines zones
elle révèle le quoi qu'il en soit une
totale défaillance du ministère en
termes de gestion des ressources
humaines
j'aimerais donc savoir quand
prendrez-vous des mesures pour débloquer
la situation afin qu'un anciennement de
qualité puissent continuer à être
assurés dans l'académie d'aix marseille
afin que tous les élèves puissent avoir
un enseignement est que les candidats
inscrits sur liste complémentaire qui
n'ont pas démérité
puis c'est être recrutés comme la
situation l'exigé merci la parole et à
madame najat vallaud belkacem ministres
éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député guy teissier
peut-être d'abord pour qu'on y voit plus
clair vous nous parlez de l'académie
d'aix marseille juste pour rappel pour
l'ensemble de l'assemblée entre 2008 et
2012 dans cette académie ce sont 1500 18
postes qui ont été supprimés entre 2013
et 2017 dans cette même académie ce sont
mille six cent vingt postes qui ont été
créés donc monsieur le député oui nous
créons des postes et d'ailleurs pour
vous répondre sur le premier degré rien
qu'à la rentrée qui vient la rentrée
2010 est ce sont encore 200 nouveaux
postes qui vont être créés pour le
premier degré ce qui va permettre je
vous remercie de l'appeler de vaud veut
d'avoir cette priorité aux primaires
cette pré scolarisation des enfants de
moins de 3 ans eu plus de mettre que des
classes qui fonctionne si bien mais
aussi des moyens pour remplacer les
enseignants absents pour assurer la
formation continue des professeurs
monsieur le député je vais vous dire
tout de même que c'était surtout cela
que vous reviendrez si le programme de
monsieur fillon s'appliquer que au bas
mot entre 100 et 150 mille postes
d'enseignants sont supprimés demain mais
bon revenons à votre question vous
disiez il y a ces dernières semaines en
effet des enseignants qui se sont
absentés et vous regretter qu'on n'ait
pas fait appel à des listes
complémentaires pour les remplacer parce
que la règle est simple dans ces cas là
on fait appel à des postes contractuels
monsieur le député pour une raison
simple c'est que ceux qui sont sur liste
complémentaire
eh bien ils n'ont pas suivi la formation
initiale que nous avons prévu désormais
pour tous nos enseignants et donc à
partir de la toussaint je vous le
confirme dans toutes les académies ça
n'est pas aux listes complémentaires que
nous faisons appel mais aux contractuels
et les contractuels bénéficient d'une
formation qui leur est propre et sont
d'ailleurs accompagné pour passer le
concours à leur tour bref monsieur le
député nous nous accordons sur un point
une fois n'est pas coutume c'est que
dans votre académie comme ailleurs les
besoins existent et que pour cela il
faut continuer à créer des postes
merci madame la parole est à m